we were invited inside the russian
mission to the un the building behind me
which has pictures of vladimir putin
casts of russian coats of arms on the
wall this is where the russian
ambassadors to the un write their
speeches where they work out quite
frankly how on earth to defend the
indefensible i began by asking russia's
deputy ambassador to the un dmitry
polyansky about those threats that
russia is making of nuclear war and if
that is the right thing
if russia is provoked by nato if russia
is attacked by nato i don't know
so we are we are nuclear power
why not you think that's a legitimate
thing to be saying though i don't think
it's the right thing to be saying but
though it's not the right thing to uh
to threaten russia and to try to
interfere so
when you're dealing with the nuclear
power of course you have to calculate
all the possible outcomes of of your
behavior that's what i'm going to say
is russia committing more crimes in
ukraine i don't think we're committing
war crimes in ukraine of course it's not
up to me to to assess i'm not there
you're not there you're looking at the
videos you're looking at the
the
many videos who are considered to be
fake news you believe one thing i
believe another thing so we need to
understand when this whole thing is over
and then only then we can judge are you
saying that the civilian
homes playgrounds hospitals theaters
have not been targeted by russia
they were not targeted
and you know it's very well we said from
the very beginning
that our military is not the threat for
civilian population ukraine can i show
you what the u.s believes is evidence of
war crimes these are pictures taken by
our colleagues
associated press independent news site
these are apartments
on fire in mariupol hit by russian
missiles uh how do you know it's russian
missiles
because there is a cell defense is your
suggestion that the ukrainians
i will tell you
it can it can uh it can easily come from
ukraine from the center of the city it
happened in harkov it happened in
mariupol because they have their own
missile uh launchers
and uh a lot of cases that i know are
reported from ukrainian missiles
themselves ambassador with respect i
think that's preposterous
the idea that this amount of this amount
of destruction i think it's quite it's
quite logical it's not proportional
mr polyansky may not believe that russia
is committing war crimes in ukraine but
the us certainly does they formally
declared today that they believe that
russia are committing war crimes in
ukraine russia
cutting an increasingly isolated figure
not just here in new york at the un but
around the world too